all right so imagine you just won in
eSports tournament you grinded for hours
you worked super hard and now you're
owed nearly $50,000 except all you walk
home with is 500 bucks and a monitor and
the crazy thing is this actually
happened it's all because of weird
Japanese gaming laws a bizarro legal
loophole to get around them and a
protest started by one of the greatest
Street Fighter players of all time
[Music]
alright let's start at the beginning way
back in 2017 a group called the Japanese
eSports union or je su was formed with
the goal of promoting and growing
eSports and one of their main promises
was that they were gonna raise him in a
prize money Japanese eSports tournaments
could offer see Japanese gambling laws
are really really strict so strict in
fact that many lawyers believe that
eSports would be considered gambling
under those insane lawn
for example the five-dollar entry fee
you might pay to play in a street
fighter or smash tournament apparently
Japanese law might consider that betting
on a sporting event which is illegal
yeah it's messed up anyway those same
laws the limit how much money are
allowed to offer as a prize for an
eSports or gambling event
it's basically capped out at a hundred
thousand yen which is about nine hundred
thirty dollars and that's not a lot by
eSport standards when the jsut burst
onto the scene back in 2017 they
proposed a licensing system as a sort of
loophole to get around the prize
restriction because if you are a
licensed player it was no longer prize
money it was simply compensation for
hours of work all of a sudden the
gambling laws presumably don't apply
because the tournament is free and all
the players who are winning something
are licensed so this all sounds pretty
good right well former Evo and Capcom
Cup champion momochi disagrees when the
licensing system first came out he
published a blog post criticizing it and
still doesn't have a license despite
having been offered one several times he
doesn't like how the JSU has full say
over who does and doesn't get a license
but we're gonna get more into his
criticisms later for now know that he
still doesn't have a license that brings
us to this past weekend when momochi won
the Asia premier street fighter
tournament at tokyo game show his grand
prize should have been 5 million yen
which is approximately forty six
thousand one hundred dollars instead
according to a statement that momochi
made on stream that was then translated
by fighting game commentator and
personality Juna all he got was five
hundred fifty bucks and a nice monitor
so understandably people are upset I
didn't vote she get his prize money well
again it's cuz he doesn't have a license
and this is when we get back to his
criticism in that blog post he said that
it's not that he's against licensing in
general it's that he's not so sure about
the jsut
who are an unelected non-government
affiliated entity getting final say over
who is and isn't an esports pro see the
JSU does reserve the right to deny a
license to anyone on top of that they
only give out licenses for certain games
leaving some games like smash rainbow 6
and even the League of Legends out of
the system for the last couple of years
the JSU is basically given a license to
whoever they want to on top of that they
also give licenses to whoever places in
the money at a streetfighter event in
Japan but what about everybody who
doesn't make top 8 aren't they still
eSports pros momochi points to people
like choco Wonka his wife or his
students who don't necessarily top 8
every tournament they attend or anything
but they still consider themselves
eSports professionals the way momochi
sees it why do the jsut get hit aside
that these people aren't real pros why
do they not get to make money playing
Street Fighter now momochi doesn't
necessarily touch on this but the jsut
is not a government body nobody's really
put this legal loophole to the test I
think it's fair to be skeptical of any
organization just popping up and
declaring themselves the arbiter of
eSports no matter what country you're in
and not having a license didn't stop
momochi from winning almost 13,000
dollars by winning eva japan now evo
japan tries to get around the gambling
laws by allowing everybody to enter for
free but still it's an eSports event in
Japan
doesn't the licensing thing have to come
into play meanwhile you were a middle
school student won a 5 million yen
puzzle & Dragons tournament didn't see a
cent of the prize pool that's because
the jsut only gives players between 13
and 15 junior licenses which prevent
their holders from collecting any prize
money at all all right this isn't just
my wild attack on the jsut there is
absolutely another side to this while
they are an unelected body they have
been doing their thing for a few years
now and people are getting paid their
system is working and sure it's not
great that an organization that isn't
necessarily connected to the Japanese
fighting game scene is able to decide
who does and doesn't deserve to earn
prize money but I suppose it's good that
at least someone out there is earning
their did it a couple of years ago
nobody was getting any money
there was a smash tournament where the
winner once won a couple of bags of rice
I think there was a tournament where
somebody went a year supply of instant
ramen I don't know about you but I'll
take cash over cup noodles any day on
the other hand we have the jsut who are
trying to make things better for eSports
players in Japan
but maybe aren't going about it in the
best way possible personally I respect
emoji for standing his ground but I also
understand why some of his peers have
taken the licenses getting paid is
pretty nice there is one thing I have a
pretty strong stance against though
Capcom recently added a clause to their
Pro to a rule book stating that any
player who resides in Japan needs to
have a je su license to receive their
prize money and while that might fly for
tournaments to take place in Japan that
doesn't make any sense returns to take
place in any other part of the world
that's messed up
Toula Japan's wild gambling laws prevent
players from earning their prize money
anywhere else in the world if a Moche
wins capcom cup he deserves his money
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]